- We're playing Telephone Pictionary!
(upbeat music)
Here's how it works, we're taking a
news story and having someone
draw out that news story.
We'll take that picture to someone else
and have them try and
guess what the story says.
Then we'll move on to another person
to try and draw out the same story.
Confused?
Not to worry, but here's today's story.
(upbeat music)
Tickets for the new movie
went on sale this week,
shattering "Hunger Games" sales records.
(upbeat music)
- Star Wars stuff,
Darth Vader, lightsaber,
monies, monies, monies!
- Some sort of welder
or radioactive engineers
helmet being hit with a bat.
Oh this is definitely Star Wars!
I got my tickets, I got my
tickets for "Star Wars."
I'm seeing it!
- I have to draw it now?
- No words, no words!
- Dammit!
(laughter)
That's Yoda, that's Chewbacca,
and money is spewing
out of his lightsaber.
- Clearly like, ghost cat money,
dog cat money is not a news story.
- (laughs) Are you sure?
- I don't know, I'm not sure.
I'm not sure of anything right now.
The best kind of money, cat dog money.
- Ned wins so far!
- I don't even know
where to start (laughs)!
(upbeat music)
- What is this (laughs)?
Um, I think that's poop.
Yes, cats + poop face = money?
I mean I wouldn't be surprised
with half the headlines you see nowadays.
(upbeat music)
- And that was the game,
Telephone Pictionary.
Try it at home, tell us what you get.
Hopefully not cat poop face money.
I don't know, sorry Star Wars.